Welcome to the deep dive.
Have you ever come across
stories, maybe from the world of
fashion or Hollywood, especially
involving young women and just
felt this, this pole, this, you
know, undeniable urge to step?
In Oh absolutely.
That feeling like you need to
protect them somehow.
Shield them.
Exactly.
Maybe even save them.
And it feels so natural, right?
Like it comes from Good Place,
empathy concern.
Totally.
It's a very human impulse.
But what if, and this is what
we're diving into today, what if
that very instinct, you know, as
well meaning as it is, actually
kind of obscure something
deeper, a more complex truth?
Like the solution we jump to
isn't really a solution at all.
Precisely what if it's actually
a bigger problem in disguise,
undermining the very strength
the the agency we should
probably be celebrating instead?
OK.
I see where you're going.
So we're looking at
vulnerability but also
surprising strength.
Yes, today we're really going
deep into these narratives where
you find profound vulnerability
right alongside immense, often
really surprising strength.
The goal here is to challenge
your own assumptions.
You know about who really needs
saving.
And to explore what it actually
means to be, as the source
material puts it, a grown ass
woman.
Exactly that, even when that
woman might be, well, remarkably
young.
It's about seeing that spirit,
that self possession, right?
It sounds like we're navigating
a really complex intersection
here.
You've got the modeling world,
the entertainment industry, high
stakes stuff, definitely.
And then you have that deep
seated societal thing, that
impulse to protect people we see
as vulnerable.
And mixing with that, is this
really powerful, sometimes kind
of overlooked idea of individual
agency, the power someone has
over their own life?
Yeah, it's definitely not black
and white, is it?
It's nuanced.
For sure.
And for this deep dive, we've
got some pretty compelling
sources lined up.
There's a really raw, almost
confessional account from a
supermodel talking about some
harrowing experiences.
OK.
And then there's a piece that's
more of a personal reflection on
those protective feelings we
were just talking about, plus an
analysis of how some celebrity
careers just completely defy
easy labels.
So a good mix of perspectives
then, giving us a lot to chew
on.
I think so.
It sets the stage for a really
interesting discussion unpacking
these, well, challenging ideas.
It is.
Absolutely.
So our mission today is pretty
clear.
I think we really want to unpack
these intricate complexities,
you know, the space between
vulnerability and that kind of
unyielding strength.
And challenge ourselves and you,
the listener, on those
assumptions we have about
protection.
Head on, especially when we see
young women navigating these
incredibly tough, sometimes
frankly predatory industries.
Ultimately, we're exploring what
it truly means to be a grown ass
woman.
Which, according to the sources,
involves being brave, smart,
fiercely independent.
Driven by her own vision, her
own dreams.
Recognizing she's nobody's
property.
And the really profound part is
that insight that this can be
true even if she's, what, 1415?
Embodying this self possession,
this strategic intelligence that
just seems way beyond her years
sometimes.
It's fascinating.
A grotesque industry, A hard
truth unpacked.
OK, so let's let's start by
pulling back the curtain.
Our deep dive kicks off with a
really stark, and I think
necessary confession.
It's from supermodel Cameron
Russell.
Right, the source highlights
what she calls her truth.
And she uses a really strong
word to describe the industry
that made her famous grotesque.
Wow, that's blunt.
It is.
It's not just a story.
It feels like a revelation, you
know, but the paradox of an
industry that sells beauty but
underneath it all can prey on
innocence, youth.
It definitely hits you right
away, sort of a gut punch to
pull you into that.
Unsettling.
Reality.
Yeah, no kidding.
And just to get a bit more
context from the source, Cam and
Russell's entry into this whole
world, it was incredibly early,
almost accidental, it sounds
like.
How so?
She was scouted as a teenager
just swimming in Maine.
Wow, that young.
Yeah, and the source paints this
picture of someone really naive,
describes her as being a sucked
into the runway world before she
even knew it S&M meant.
S&M, right?
Sadomasochism.
Not exactly standard teenage
vocabulary.
Exactly, the fact that she was
exposed to that kind of world
that, you know, the implied
darker stuff before she even
understood the terminology, it
just powerfully shows the
environment she was thrown into
an.
Environment she was totally
unprepared for.
Fundamentally unprepared.
And what she talks about
enduring, I mean, it goes way
beyond.
Just like the usual pressures of
a tough job.
The source describes a pattern
of exploitation blurring lines.
What kind of things?
Well, it recounts the kiss from
the grown photographer when she
was 16. 16 OK, it's not
professional, that's predatory.
Clearly a total violation of
trust boundaries, especially for
a minor.
Then there were the constant
jailbait comments.
That language, it's not just
inappropriate, it's deliberately
sexualizing her youth.
It's gross.
Totally predatory, shows this
complete disregard for her as a
person.
And then there's this specific,
really haunting image.
You see sucker lips painted on
by a makeup artist.
Wow, that's incredibly visceral.
Isn't it?
It's not just about makeup.
It shows how her image was
manipulated, sexualized, turned
into something she probably
didn't even fully get her
consent to at that age.
So it paints this chilling
picture, an industry where, for
many, these young women weren't
seen as people, but as objects.
Valuable objects, yeah.
To be shaped, consumed for
profit, yeah.
Their innocence, their bodies.
Just commodities, yeah.
And the source talks about her
memoir to the title alone says a
lot.
How to make herself agreeable to
everyone?
Wow, that really resonates with
what you were just saying.
Doesn't it?
The source calls the memoir an
ugly, necessary confession.
Ugly because of the awful truths
that exposes, the abuse, the
demeaning treatment, the whole
system.
But necessary, because this
stuff often stays hidden right
behind the glamour.
Precisely, and the industry seen
through her eyes.
It functions like this
dehumanizing machine.
That's the word.
The source uses the.
Machine, yeah.
That says this machine eats up
young women's beauty, choose
their innocence for profit, and
leaves them to sort of sort out
the therapy bills later.
That's a powerful metaphor, a
cold and different machine.
It suggests it's systemic,
right?
Not just a few bad apples.
Exactly.
It implies this deeply
entrenched way of operating that
just prioritizes profit over the
well-being, The mental health of
these young women caught in it.
It's a very stark indictment.
In that indictment, that's why
the source really emphasizes the
bravery here.
Cameron Russell speaking her
truth out loud like that.
It takes immense courage, you'd
think, to expose the ugly side
of the industry that you know
made you famous.
Especially when you've been
taught, like her title says, to
be agreeable to everyone
dismantling the facade, Yeah.
And as listeners, when we hear
these kinds of raw stories, I
think many of us do have that
immediate, visceral reaction.
For sure it ignites that
protective instinct, right?
Outrage.
A sense of injustice.
You feel for someone so young,
seemingly so vulnerable, even
though, as we'll get into,
there's incredible bravery there
too.
Forces you to confront these
unconscionable truths, that
behind the glitter there can be
real pain, real exploitation.
It's hard not to feel that urge
to jump in to fix it, protect
them somehow.
The instinct to protect and it's
unintended consequences.
OK, so here's where things get
really interesting and very
human.
Our source writer, after hearing
Cameron Russell's story, shares
this incredibly powerful raw
reaction, something many of us
can probably relate to.
What was the reaction?
Not just outrage, but pure
protective rage.
You know that feel like that gut
level almost primal urge when
someone you care about or just
empathize with seems threatened?
Yeah, I know exactly what you
mean.
It's intense, and it's a
compelling pivot because the
source then talks about the
author's own personal experience
that kind of amplified this
feeling.
Oh really?
What?
Was that they talk about dating
a woman years ago who was
modeling with Elite Petite in
New York and the author
describes her as tough as hell
and gorgeous.
So right away you get the sense
of someone strong, captivating.
Tough as hell, but still evoking
that protective feeling.
Apparently so.
Their life together sounded
pretty unconventional.
Riding with the motorcycle club.
Crashing 12 step conferences.
Wow.
OK, so not exactly a shrinking
Violet.
Not at all.
It changed the picture of
someone resilient, independent,
able to handle herself in
challenging situations.
Yet still this powerful
protective instinct emerged in
the author.
And despite her toughness, maybe
even because of it, the author
felt this, yeah, visceral,
overwhelming need to protect
her.
The source describes it as
feeling brotherly, fatherly,
boyfriend all at once.
It's a lot rolled into one.
Isn't an intense desire to
shield her?
The urge was described as
absolute, like a primal command.
Protect her, shut the door,
guard the gate, burn the club to
the ground if you have to.
Whoa.
That's not just concern, that's
almost violent in its intensity.
Eradicate the threat.
Totally shield her completely,
no matter the cost.
And the source says that exact
same feeling surged up again
hearing Cameron Russell talk
about predators with casting
couches.
So it underscores how deep
seated that response is when we
perceive a threat to someone we
see as vulnerable, even if
they're all so strong.
Right.
And that intense emotional
reaction leads straight to this
immediate gut level solution the
source presents.
One that feels, you know, really
appealing at first.
Which is shut it all down.
Ban child modeling forever.
Replace all that vulnerability
with perfect AI babes, dolls
that never get harassed, never
starve themselves to death,
never post a tell all about the
scumbag photographer in Paris.
The AI solution, yeah, I can see
the appeal, especially when
you're feeling that.
It feels clean, if the source
puts it.
It promises a world without
harm, no exploitation, a neat
technological fix for a messy
human problem, the ultimate
protection by just getting rid
of the risk altogether.
But then, and this is the
crucial bit, the source just
immediately calls it bullshit.
Right, that's stark rejection.
It's fascinating, isn't it?
This solution seems so logical,
so clean, so final, but it's
dismissed as fundamentally
flawed.
Which really makes you ask why?
Why does this intuitive techie
solution fall so short?
Why is it, you know, bullshit?
Well, according to the source,
it falls short because it
ignores this kind of dark joke
about a terrifying gender
disparity and vulnerability.
A dark joke.
Yeah, the source lays it out
starkly.
The dog joke is that if a date
goes bad for a man, he goes home
alone with a bruised ego.
If a date goes bad for a woman,
she might end up dead in the
ground.
That's brutal, but discurbingly
resonant with reality,
unfortunately.
It really is.
It speaks to this deep,
pervasive societal fear rooted
in, well, actual violence
against women.
The stakes are just terrifyingly
higher.
So the authors personal fear,
that feeling of wanting to stand
outside every hotel room with a
baseball bat.
It's not just about control.
It's presented as this raw,
visceral response to a reality
where women face much higher
risks of severe violence, sexual
assault, even death in
situations that might seem minor
to others.
It's about that systemic
vulnerability.
And that really does bring it
into focus.
This whole scenario highlights
that gender disparity, that deep
fear driving the protective
impulse.
Which, while well-intentioned.
Right.
It's well-intentioned, but it
often massively oversimplifies
things.
And, crucially, it overlooks,
sometimes even kind of
suppresses, individual agency.
How so?
It suggests our fear, our desire
to prevent harm, can
paradoxically lead us to
solutions that disempower the
very people we want to protect.
We try to remove all risk.
And in doing so, we might remove
their ability to choose, to be
resilient, to learn, to
determine their own path.
Exactly.
It's this profound tension the
source forces us to confront,
the impulse to save versus the
unintended consequences of that
impulse.
The true protection isn't maybe
about insulation, but
empowerment.
Unveiling agency.
The power we often forget.
So OK, if blanket protection or
just deleting people with AI
isn't the answer, what does this
mean for how we see young women
in these tough industries?
This is where the deep dive
takes a really surprising,
almost revolutionary turn, I
think.
How does it shift?
The source directly confronts
that protective instinct we were
just talking about, challenges
it with a profound truth.
It fundamentally shifts the
perspective away from just
seeing victims.
Towards recognizing their
strength, their capability,
their bravery.
Exactly.
Their inherent strength, their
strategic thinking, and yeah,
their undeniable bravery.
And there's this pivotal moment
in the source, right where the
author voices this core
contradiction to that protective
rage.
It's blunt, but essential.
What's the quote?
That fear bumps right into the
truth.
She's not my thing, daughter.
And even if she was, she's not
my thing property.
Wow.
OK, that it's hard.
It really does, because it
directly challenges those
paternalistic views, that habit
of seeing young women as
possessions or extensions of
someone else or just things to
be controlled.
It's a Declaration of
Independence, a redefinition of
ownership where there isn't any.
Exactly.
It demands we see everyone,
regardless of age or gender, as
autonomous, brave, smart,
independent, with their own
vision, their own dreams,
fundamentally their own
property.
And that realization leads
straight into this pivotal idea
of agency.
The source puts it so
powerfully.
Here's what we forget when we
fixate on the worst case.
These girls.
Yeah, girls sometimes have more
agency than we like to admit.
That's the key insight, isn't
it?
We focus so much on the danger,
the potential harm.
That we overlook their inner
strengths, their strategic
minds, their resilience.
Yeah, and agency here isn't just
about having choices, it's about
self determination, right?
Acting independently,
strategically, making tough
calls even in messed up
situations.
Relentlessly pursuing their own
goals despite huge, often
predatory obstacles.
It's about their brave capacity
to navigate their own lives on
their own terms.
And the source gives really
specific, compelling examples of
this agency in action within the
industry.
It's not passive endurance, it's
active navigation.
Like what give me example.
I feel like this observation.
They stand in a casting line 400
deep.
Right, you can see that as
desperate.
Or you could see it as
incredible persistence,
unwavering ambition, fierce
determination despite
overwhelming odds they choose to
be there.
Enduring rejection after
rejection, critique after
critique.
Holding on to hope.
That speaks to amazing
psychological fortitude, a clear
vision for what they want.
Exactly.
And then there's that grim
reality the source mentions.
They tolerate the creeps.
Which sounds like victimhood.
But the source suggests reading
it differently, that it's often
a calculated navigation of
horrible situations, a shrewd
understanding of the
environment, and a strategic
decision.
A calculus maybe, to endure
certain things as a means to an
end.
An.
Unfortunate part of the hustle.
Yeah, a grim part, but it speaks
to a kind of pragmatic
resilience, compartmentalizing,
powering through for a bigger
goal.
They often know what's up and
they choose the reactions to
serve their objective, achieving
their vision, their dreams,
being smart about it.
And then it says they game the
system.
Right.
Which means they're not just
pawns, right?
Not passive exactly.
It implies they actively find
ways to leverage the system,
bypass its flaws, use their
intelligence, their
adaptability, their social
skills.
Understanding unspoken rules,
finding loopholes, networking,
negotiating.
Yeah.
It's an active role within this
complex, often murky structure
shows keen intelligence and a
drive for self advancement.
They're smart, actively trying
to make their vision happen.
And maybe the most provocative
bit, and this really pushes our
thinking, the source says.
They're not just prey, they're
predators in their own right.
Whoa, okay, that's a strong
reframing it.
Is it's meant to shock us out of
conventional thinking, but it
highlights this crucial or maybe
uncomfortable aspect of their
agency.
They often possess this
shrewdness, sharp with
competitive edge strategic mind,
things usually attributed only
to people in power.
So they can be assertive,
competitive, focused on their
own success, maybe even at
other's expense sometimes.
It suggests that, yeah, they're
not helpless.
They're dynamic forces shaping
their own careers.
It's a challenging idea that a
young woman can be both
vulnerable and possess a kind of
killer instinct.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, the source draws
these powerful parallels,
calling them early achievers.
Ah right, that comparison is
really insightful.
Puts them in a broader context
of intense high performance
fields.
Exactly.
It says they're the same as
gymnasts, chess prodigies, child
actors, Figure skaters.
Think about the lives those kids
lead.
The examples are striking, too.
The ones who starve to make
weight, who wake up at 4:00 AM
to skate the same jump 600
times.
That level of discipline, the
sacrifice, the singular focus.
It's not casual, is it?
It's lives dedicated to
excellence, often a huge
personal cost.
This comparison highlights those
shared traits, relentless
dedication, sacrifice, ambition,
and this fierce willingness to
push their own boundaries,
physical and mental, to achieve
their vision.
It shows this exceptional Dr.
even when very young,
demonstrates their profound
bravery.
And the outcome, the source
observes, is that sometimes they
outplay the wolves.
Right.
It's not a guarantee, obviously,
but it powerfully emphasizes
that agency intelligence
resilience can lead to triumph.
Exactly.
Despite facing huge challenges,
predatory forces, they're not
always just victims.
They have the capacity,
capacity, the smarts, the
foresight to navigate and
sometimes overcome the system's
trying to exploit them.
It's a testament to their
incredible resilience, their
ability to be brave and smart
even when society underestimates
them.
Truly, nobody's property.
And that's exactly why we want
you, our listener, to really
challenge your own assumptions
about victimhood versus
empowerment.
Are we automatically seeing
fragility, maybe because of our
own protective feelings and
diminishing their strength?
Or are we truly acknowledging
their incredible, maybe
sometimes uncomfortable,
resilience and strategic skill?
Are we seeing them as helpless
or as individuals with powerful
agency, even at a young age, who
are fiercely their own property,
driven by their own clear
visions and dreams?
This shift in perspective is
fundamental to understanding
their complex, brave journeys.
Sydney Sweeney's master plan.
A case study in killer instinct.
OK, so to make this idea,
agency, this grown ass woman
concept really concrete and
contemporary, our source gives
us a fantastic real world
example, the actress Sydney
Sweeney.
Yeah, very prominent right now.
Exactly.
A familiar face and her story as
a source tells it really seems
to encapsulate this idea of self
determination and strategic
smarts.
Well, the source acknowledges
her public image first, right?
Calling her arguably one of the
most objectified women in
Hollywood today.
Big boobs, big gaze, big deal.
Yeah, that's the perception many
people have based on her roles,
her appearances.
It's easy to look at that and
think she just kind of fell into
it.
That she's just a product of the
industry gaze or her success is
mostly about looks?
Right, But then the source drops
this surprising truth that just
completely refutes that passive
idea.
What's that?
That says point blank.
Did she stumble into that?
No.
OK, unequivocal.
Totally.
It immediately sets the stage
for revealing the sheer agency,
the strategic brilliance, the
relentless Dr. behind her rise.
It directly challenges the idea
that her success is just looks,
her luck or the industry's
doing.
Instead, it paints her as the
architect of her own destiny.
And the specific detail that
follows is, well, it's pretty
striking.
Speaks volumes about her
foresight and planning.
What is it?
The source reveals she sat her
parents down in Washington state
or Oregon, I think, and gave
them a PowerPoint presentation
explaining exactly how she'd get
where she is now.
Get out of here A PowerPoint as
a teenager, that's what it.
Says imagine that, a teenager
living at home presenting A
comprehensive multi year
business plan for her entire
career to her parents.
That's not just ambition, that's
meticulous strategic thinking.
Astounding dedication for
someone that young.
She was incredible initiative,
right and understanding of the
industry, a really clear vision
for her dreams.
Brave, smart and clear on her
path.
Absolutely mind boggling.
And it wasn't just a vague idea
like I want to be famous.
It was concrete, actionable.
The source highlights her
detailed strategy.
Plan A.
Plan B.
Plan C.
Wow, contingency planning and
everything.
It's not a wish, it's a
blueprint.
Shows his capacity for
foresight, anticipating
obstacles, devising multiple
routes to her goal.
She wasn't just hoping for the
best.
It speaks to this profound
intentionality.
Commitment indicates she's
really in control of her
trajectory.
Not someone being passively
guided.
Someone actively directing her
own destiny, assorting her
agency, making sure she's
nobody's property but her own.
And what really stands out here,
what the source powerfully
highlights, is this comparison.
It makes it really uncovers A
societal double standard.
What's the comparison?
The same hustle people cure for
when it's a teenage boy training
for the NBA.
That's insightful think about
how we view young male athletes
with that kind of dedication,
practicing constantly, planning
their careers young, making huge
sacrifices.
We.
Celebrate it, right?
Laud their ambition, their
drive, their killer instinct as
admirable signs of discipline
success.
It's absolutely true we cheer
that intensity, that focus in
boys.
But when a young woman shows the
exact same strategic planning,
ambition, dedication, like a
detailed PowerPoint mapping her
career, it often gets
overlooked, doesn't it?
We're overshadowed by talk about
her looks, or dismissed as luck
or just being a product.
Yeah, this comparison forces us
to look at that double standard.
Why is it admirable in one
context, but maybe seen as less
significant or even, I don't
know, calculating in another?
It challenges us to see that the
same hustle, the same fierce
intelligence and vision is just
as powerful, just as indicative
of agency, no matter who has it.
So the conclusion the source
draws from Sweeney's story
really hammers home the core
message of this deep dive, which
is that's not a helpless little
lamb, that's a grown ass woman
with a killer instinct, right?
Not someone needing saving.
Some with immense strength,
formidable strategic
intelligence, fierce
independence.
It underscores that idea that
true agency is about knowing
what you want and actively,
bravely, intelligently going
after it with a clear vision,
ensuring she's her own property,
accountable only to her dreams.
The embodiment of drive and self
determination, even young.
The peril of perfect AI Why
deleting humans isn't the
answer.
OK, so let's circle back to that
initial kind of elegant sounding
fix for all the exploitation
problems we talked about the the
idea of just replacing real
women with perfect AI dolls.
Why the technological solution?
Our source.
Really dives deeper into why
this isn't just imperfect, but
potentially way more dangerous,
more insidious, and ultimately
kind of a denial of human
resilience than it first seems.
It has that seductive allure,
though, a clean fix for a messy
human problem.
Exactly.
The source reiterates that
immediate gut reaction, that
emotional appeal you might feel
when faced with the ugliness.
Fine, burn the whole system
down.
If we hate what happens to real
girls, replace them with perfect
AI dolls.
No more trauma, no more
predators.
Everybody wins.
Yeah, on.
The surface.
It sounds like a utopia, doesn't
it?
Technologically achieved
Nirvana.
No suffering, no abuse.
Just flawless, controllable
virtual beings fulfilling the
demand for images without any
human cost.
No messy emotions, no therapy
bills needed.
It promises total eradication of
vulnerability by just removing
the vulnerable, the ultimate
fantasy of a problem solved.
But that leads to this
incredibly important question.
The source pushes us toward what
really happens when you try to
protect vulnerable people?
But just erasing them from the
picture entirely?
Is real protection found in
deletion?
In removal.
Or is it found in empowerment,
resilience and actually changing
the systems that cause the harm
rather than just treating the
symptoms?
The source argues really
strongly against this seemingly
benign solution.
It explains the flaw by
introducing this idea of the
modeling and entertainment
industry as a vast, complex
biosphere.
A biosphere.
That's a critical metaphor,
isn't it, for understanding the
scale?
Totally.
It's never just the Cindy
Crawfords on the catwalk in
Paris, as the source points out.
That top tier?
The famous supermodels?
They're only the most visible,
most glamorous part, and often,
ironically, maybe the most
protected part of this huge
ecosystem of image, performance
and, yes, exploitation.
And the source really drills
down into the sheer diversity of
roles and people in this
sprawling biosphere, shows how
deep the demand for certain
looks and performances goes
across all levels of society.
Because it's huge network,
right?
Yeah, it includes showroom.
Girls in Atlanta may be working
long hours, low pay, still
needing a certain look.
Department store shoots in
Albuquerque less glamorous Be
still objectifying, far from
high fashion.
OK.
So much broader than just runway
models.
Way broader cruise ship
performers, often isolated,
vulnerable, restrictive
contracts, ring girls at fights,
teen beauty Queens and their
intense pageant moms, all in
these hyper competitive,
appearance focused worlds.
And child actors too, facing
huge pressure.
Yup.
And now TikTok influencers
pushing shape wear, constantly
performing, monetizing their
bodies, facing intense global
scrutiny.
It just shows how pervasive the
demand is and how many people,
often very young, get drawn into
this ecosystem, each facing
their own vulnerabilities.
And here's the critical, really
cynical insight the source wants
us to get.
And it feels devastatingly
accurate.
What is it?
When you protect the top by
raising the humans, you don't
protect the rest.
You just push the exploitation
sideways, deeper into cheaper
corners where the same girls
hustle for the same scraps.
Yeah, that's the core argument
against the AI fix.
Exactly.
It highlights that the
underlying demand for these
images for youth, certain
bodies, a specific performance.
It doesn't just vanish because
the visible human models are
gone.
The.
Demand persists unaddressed, and
the exploitation just moves.
Shifts to less regulated, more
obscure, often far more
dangerous corners where
oversight is minimal,
protections are 0, and the cost
of vulnerability is even higher.
The truly vulnerable and the
less visible, less glamorous,
often more desperate parts,
they're left even more exposed,
operating in the shadows,
chasing the same limited, often
predatory opportunities.
And the source delivers that
utterly cynical yet probably
chillingly accurate conclusion
and the same and still cash the
checks.
That hammers at home.
Doesn't it?
The underlying power structures,
the systemic demand for
objectification, the ultimate
beneficiaries, they remain
unchanged.
The problem isn't the human
models, it's the ingrained
societal demand and the system's
profiting from it.
So replacing humans at the top
doesn't dismantle the demand or
the profit motive, it just
reconfigures the supply chain of
vulnerability.
Leaves the real perpetrators
untouched, maybe even bolder,
while those at the bottom become
even more expendable, more
unseen.
And this analysis is so
important because it emphasizes
that fixing complex societal
problems just at the symptom
level, like swapping models for
AI without tackling the root
causes, the.
Underlying demand, the power
structures, the systemic issues
creating vulnerability.
It's ultimately ineffective.
Worse than ineffective, it's a
dangerous illusion.
It can actually lead to new,
maybe more insidious, definitely
less visible forms of harm.
Pushing exploitation
underground, making it harder to
regulate, identify or protect
anyone.
It's a dangerous illusion of a
solution that just reshuffles
the deck of exploitation without
changing the game.
And it's a profound denial of
human bravery, isn't it,
Suggesting the problem is the
exploited person's
vulnerability, not the exploiter
that undermines basic human
dignity?
Finding the balance, supporting
agency, not erasing it.
OK, so if the answers aren't
simple protection, that might
disempower, and they're
definitely not the chilling idea
of just deleting humans, where
does that leave us?
Where do we go?
That's a big question.
Our source, after taking us
through all this complexity,
ultimately brings us back to
this powerful recurring theme,
the central idea that anchors
the whole argument.
It comes through with real
clarity.
Yeah, what's fascinating is how
it keeps returning to this core
message that's been building
throughout, the source
explicitly says.
Every time I run the loop from
Cameron's grotesque truth to my
motorcycle Club X to my fear for
every brave girl I've ever
known, I come back to the same
place.
Agency, independence.
They're grown ass women even
when they're 15 sometimes.
It's not just a maybe, is it?
It's presented as this firm
conclusion drawn from reflection
observation.
Absolutely.
It's this powerful
acknowledgement that these young
women, despite age, despite
perceived vulnerability, have
this profound self
determination, inner fortitude,
strategic intelligence that
demands respect.
It's asserting they are
fundamentally brave, smart,
independent people with their
own vision, their own dreams,
absolutely nobody's property but
their own.
And this is such a critical
distinction the source makes so
powerfully.
It's really clear that
acknowledging agency,
celebrating this strength,
doesn't mean we just shrug off
predators or accept
exploitation.
Hell no, as the source says
emphatically.
Right.
It's not about complacency or
indifference to harm.
Quite the opposite.
It means we need a fundamentally
different approach to
protection.
More nuanced, more empowering.
Strengthening the individual and
the systems around them, not
erasing them or stripping their
autonomy precisely.
And the source offered
practical, actionable ideas for
real solutions.
Countering that shrugged
predators idea.
Instead of deletion, the focus
shifts to robust support
systems, stronger boundaries.
Like what kind of things?
It suggests add the guard rails,
bring the chaperones, the stage
moms, the aunties who sit in the
corner and watch the door.
OK, so not removing them, but
providing a human shield around
them?
Collective vigilance.
Active supervision.
Trusted adults present, not just
observing but ready to
intervene, creating an
environment where predators know
they're watched accountability
as possible, and brave young
women feel supported pursuing
their dreams.
And it goes further, suggesting
things that are really
empowering.
Put some teeth in the contracts,
make it easier to walk away.
That speaks directly to giving
agency real power.
Doesn't it?
Creating legal and professional
frameworks with genuine,
enforceable protection, giving
them clear rights, fair terms
and crucially, the real ability
to leave situations that are
unsafe, exploitative or just
wrong for them without huge
penalties.
Shifting the power dynamic by
giving them real actionable
leverage within the system.
Reinforcing their independence,
making sure they're never truly
trapped.
It transforms that grim idea of
tolerating creeps into having
the confident power to say no
and actually leave without fear,
letting their smart decisions
guide them.
And this leads to that
absolutely vital distinction.
The source makes the real crux
of the argument against the AI
fix, which is but don't pretend
you're saving these women by
deleting them cuts.
Right through the superficial
appeal of the tech fix.
True salvation, real protection,
doesn't come from removing the
person.
Instead, it comes from
empowering them within the
environment, building up their
defenses, their knowledge, their
support networks, their inherent
ability to assert their own
agency and make choices that
serve them, even young.
It's a profound act of respect
for their brave, independent
spirit.
And the source leaves us with
this really powerful final word.
It encapsulates everything,
forces us to confront the deep
implications.
Because when you swap them for
perfect, invulnerable AI girls,
you don't just protect the
vulnerable, you erase the brave.
And maybe, just maybe, that's
worse.
Wow.
That's the ultimate punch,
isn't?
It it really is.
It makes us face the true cost
of those well meaning but flawed
protective urges.
It's not just about preventing
harm.
It's about preserving the human
spirit, the Dr. Ambition, grit,
intelligence, the incredible
bravery of these young women
navigating complex worlds on
their terms, asserting their
right to be nobody's property.
To erase that, the source
argues, is to erase something
vital, powerful about humanity.
And that's truly the core
tension, the single most
important take away year.
The imperative to protect
individuals without stripping
away their autonomy, their
choices, their inherent
strength, their capacity for
resilience.
It's about empowering choice,
strengthening boundaries, not
removing the choices altogether
through misguided attempts at
total insulation.
Recognizing that true
empowerment isn't about
shielding from all risk that's
impossible anyway, but about
equipping people to navigate it,
to thrive despite it.
To be brave, smart, resilient in
the face of challenge.
Celebrating that these young
women are indeed grown ass
women, even at 15, with their
own brave intelligence, powerful
agency, nobody's property,
driven by their unique visions
and dreams, actively shaping
their own futures.
Outro.
Wow, what an incredible,
sometimes, yeah, challenging but
ultimately really enlightening
journey this deep dive has been.
We went from those gut wrenching
truth about exploitation so
bravely shared by Cameron
Russell.
Through that critical look at
her own protective instincts,
Maybe well meaning, but flawed.
To arrive at this ultimate
celebration of agency, bravery,
and the undeniable strength of
what it truly means to be a
grown ass woman, even when
remarkably young.
We've seen how these women are
smart, fiercely independent,
have extraordinary vision and
dreams, and are absolutely
nobody's property but their own.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, this deep dive
really shows us that true
empowerment isn't just about
insulating people from all risk
that's not achievable.
It's fundamentally about
equipping them to navigate risk,
to thrive despite challenges,
and crucially, to be brave,
resourceful, resilient when
things get tough.
Respecting their intrinsic
power, their capacity for
choice, rather than just
focusing on vulnerability.
Exactly.
Which raises an important
question for you, our listeners.
Something to carry forward from
this deep dive.
How do we as individuals, as a
society, genuinely balance that
very human impulse to protect
others?
With the imperative to foster
their agency, to celebrate their
bravery, to respect their innate
capacity for self determination.
What does true protection
actually look like when it
genuinely respects individual
power, resilience and the
capacity for growth and self
authorship, even in complex,
sometimes exploitative systems?
Yeah, Think about how these
insights might apply elsewhere,
in other areas of your life or
the world around you, wherever
you see powerful young
individuals bravely facing tough
odds.
Lots to think about.